and now only on CBS this morning here
are the new restaurants featured on this
year's Bon Apetit hot 10 number three is
a Thai restaurant ugly baby
interesting name in Brooklyn number two
is made on that's in Washington DC with
its Middle Eastern cuisine and the
number one new restaurant of the year is
Nonesuch that's an Oklahoma City
Oklahoma of course Bon Apetit
editor-at-large Andrew Knowlton and
deputy editor Julia Kramer but there's
you put this year's list together and
they join us at the table welcome back
guys thank you but I love your intro to
your intro to nonsense how did a 22 seat
tasting menu spot from three chefs who
no one has ever heard of in a city that
no national critic has ever paid
attention to become America's best new
restaurant and you're right Andrew you
take a bite and it's boom what was it I
just got goose bumps and I heard
Nonesuch watching the kindred piece and
the the effect that a list that we put
together the Bon Appetit puts together
can have that kind of effect not even
pride but also that financial thing it I
don't know teary I just still watch all
that like a proud parent proud parent
yeah what is the answer then to the baby
Oklahoma City then which is how does it
rise up out of all their other
restaurants well I mean the interesting
stories we kind of discovered I
discovered about this restaurant
Nonesuch on Instagram of all places
just one late-night session going
through the the rabbit hole looking all
these beauty and I came upon this dish
was made of ice and had all these
pickled vegetables and I took it to
Julia and I was like should I go to
Oklahoma City you gotta go I love the
role that International cuisine has an
American palates right and people are
increasingly exploring new flavors and
number five this immigrant story now and
Bay right in Oakland tell us about this
restaurant in how an immigrant brought
their experience to this country this is
an amazing story the chef night Yan was
born in a refugee camp in Thailand and
came to this country settled in the in
Texas and then in the Bay Area and then
when she was in her 20s went back to
Cambodia where her parents had fled from
the genocide in the 70s and tasted the
food there and was like oh this is what
I grew up eating I need
to cook this food in a restaurant and
then came back and opened her spot and
now it's on our list of the best
restaurants in America you guys also
track menu trends and food trends what
are you finding well we're finding
except for a number one restaurant
Nonesuch which is a tasting menu that a
lot of chefs have sort of stepped away
from that more formal tasting menu
format and they're just cooking what
they love I mean one of the restaurants
on our list
it's called ume cara cara it's in
Cambridge they only make one thing they
make a bowl of udon that's it that's it
and it's in a food court in Leslie
University which I didn't even know
existed and you walk in and there's
these 12 seats and you kind of stand
there and watch this beautiful art
happen and you eat this kind of bowl
that takes you to another place a futon
I love your descriptions one is a chilly
whisper it doesn't care if you can't
stand the heat half the fun of looking
at the pictures is reading what you guys
write I think it's such a great job
thank you guys for coming back again
thank you so long for a tasty yeah first
stop in Oklahoma City I would love to
come I still want to go to Turkey in the
Wolfe good to see you guys thank you
Andrew Knowlton and Julia Kramer head to
CBS this morning's Facebook page to see
more of bone Appetit top 10 restaurants
from around the country and read more
about the hot ten in bone Appetit
September issue no the one with the
great cover it hits stores today